man love that shirt
uh i love your work so there we go
it's uh i really want to start with a
sincere thank you i laughed my ass off
last night and it was great to see this
i just want to say thank you for making
this movie thank you
uh a million questions so i i'm so
curious uh spike jones when he's on set
is there like an unwritten rule that you
can't [ __ ] with him or is he like does
he can you still go after him
the problem going after spike is
anything you do to him it's coming back
to you tenfold like yeah
he's like i remember even i've known
spikes for a long time like in high
school if i threw a french fry on him at
lunch he's flipping the whole table over
and grabbing anything he can find and
just hitting me with it so
he comes off as this like nice sensitive
you know intellectual filmmaker but he's
real physical he could be pure hell if
you mess with him so but there is no
rules to not mess with him like no he he
gets it
so so basically it's almost like people
are afraid of messing with them no i
would say i we still give it to i
remember uh you and you you mess with
him the most the funniest thing like in
after jackass three 3d after we were
shooting the opening sequence and he's
actually diving in the background of one
of those shots in the opening secrets
shooting paintballs at aaron
meanwhile a bunch of other paintballs
are coming towards him and he got grazed
in the neck and he's like
man
jeff i think i got hit by a paintball
i'm like really he's like yeah he's
showing me his neck and i see him
opening his neck i'm like
well it looks more like a handprint he's
like what do you mean i just
what do you think would surprise jackass
fans to learn about the actual making of
the jackass movie
i mean if they were there watching it i
think they would be surprised we get any
footage at all
[Laughter]
yeah you'd be surprised how it all comes
together yeah how the sausage is made
it's like wow these guys are in charge
um but what they wouldn't be surprised
is like
what's happening is what you see it's
real like it's
you know like it's not uh
i guess it's not surprising like you
watch that you know that it's
yeah sometimes
a lot of times we have try to make it
controlled chaos but a lot of times it's
just [ __ ] chaos
and
and we kind of need it to be
sure um listen this is one of those
movies where if you had told me the
movie was four hours i would have been
like
great so um i'm just i'm just curious
how much ends up on something like this
like did you have a much longer cut like
will fans get to see an extended cut on
the blu-ray
yeah well there's a 4.5 but there is
also a big extended we we have both like
uh
yeah cause there's so many
all takes and just
yeah we use everything so then we shoot
overshoot we overshoot by almost
double yeah right like we've been
putting out a 0.5 between each movie and
this one definitely has a 4.5 and i
always just gauge you know the movie's
good if the 0.5 is as good as it is so
yeah
so i have to so what exactly what can
fans look forward to on the eventual
blu-ray
more full-frontal male nudity yes yes
than you ever wanted miles and miles of
[ __ ]
this is obviously uh it's been 10 years
since the last one do you think that
this is
could it continue with like jackass the
next generation or do you think this is
like the the curtain call on this
well sure it could continue uh will it
continue we don't know we don't make
long-term plans but
we do have fresh blood uh with new cast
members we do have a ton of ideas we
didn't shoot but we make everyone like
it's the last so we don't know yeah
honestly the the only way to make these
is as i think about it the only way we
can make these movies as if we're making
it as if as if it's the last one you
can't look down the road you we just
leave it all on the floor we shoot
everything we can think of
and
it's too scary if you're making it and
while you're making it thinking there's
going to be another one yeah oh we're
going to save this idea for the next no
it's like we're doing all the best ideas
if you guys had oh i'm out of time but
it's real fast if you guys had like an
unlimited budget and could do anything
you wanted is there a stunt that's
always been in the back pocket that you
just couldn't do because of budgetary
restraints
god well
we you know we kind of partner with
paramount and and
we want to keep the budget down
well the funny thing is we do have a
company you you had one in particular
that that became a little bit monetary
that we're not going to say because we
did get close to making it and i would
we would yeah we're gonna aim for that
one i'll say this the
usually the more expensive the stunt the
less likely it is to make the movie like
we'll set up these big elaborate things
and then that day we'll shoot we man
over here kicking himself in the nuts
and that's the funniest thing we shot
that whole day with a big expensive
thing was just
kind of a
yeah a ruse to get them bored so they
start the spontaneity all the
spontaneous stuff happens that's the
stuff that i love right like the stuff
that doesn't take any planning on that
note i got i got to stop but i really
mean it sincerely thank you for making
this thank you
you